this video is brought to you by Ray Khan
what's up wisecrack jarred again
convicted serial killer Ted Bundy is hot
right now and if you find that sentence
as weird as I do then stick around
thanks to the recent Netflix documentary
series and the clumsily titled Netflix
movie extremely wicked shockingly evil
and vile by the same director suddenly
everyone's talking about Bundy and not
in just a Wow what an awful person way
but in a that Ted Bundy was hot kinda
way so hot in fact the actor cast to
portray him was two-time MTV best
shirtless performance award winner Zac
Efron after watching the film though we
were left wondering exactly what the
movie was trying to say that's because
it makes a weird omission for a film
about a serial killer actual murder it
makes a strong stylistic choice to
deprive the audience of any scenes that
show him murdering his victims until its
final moments for most of the runtime it
seems like the film is asking us to make
up our own mind about a dude convicted
of murdering a bunch of people also
there was some necrophilia and with the
casting of the undeniably handsome Efron
it feels like the film is trying to make
some sort of statement about appearances
and what they hide this all seems kind
of weird right a movie about a serial
killer that spends the vast majority of
its running time and not on the murder
stuff but building an image of a
charming guy defending his innocence
what is the movie actually saying about
Bundy or serial killers is it about the
nature of evil is it saying anything at
all well let's find out in this what
went wrong on extremely wicked
shockingly whatever the Zac Efron Ted
Bundy movie and spoiler Ted Bundy did it
but before we get into that I want to
give a shout out to Ray Khan for
sponsoring this video
ray Connor your buds are the perfect
wireless solution for your music
listening needs believe it or not I
sometimes go to the gym and if I am
music is a must but having a wire that
goes from your ears to your pocket has
always been really awkward and with all
the moving around you do the wires get
worn and the ear buds die fast I
seriously go through like five pairs a
year since switching to Ray Kanzi 50
wireless headphones though I haven't had
any of those problems plus they're half
the price of most other premium wireless
earbuds on the market they're small
comfortable and I barely even notice one
of
wearing them they even send different
year tip options you can get a pair that
fits your ears they come in a bunch of
different styles and colors have great
sound quality and are really discreet
again the best part is that they are
half price of their competitors
so check out ray con wireless earbuds
you get 20% off your order by clicking
the link in the description and now back
to the show
alright guys first a quick recap
smokin'-hot law student Theodore Bundy
meets secretary Liz Kendall at a bar
where they hit it off and start dating
not long after handsome Ted gets
arrested as a suspect in the murders of
multiple young women from the Seattle
area
despite being initially released and
insisting to Liz he's innocent Ted and
his ripped ABS are soon arrested again
and put in jail to await trial but he
escapes only to get caught a week later
and sent back to prison still protesting
his innocence he escapes again but this
time makes it all the way to Florida
where suspiciously enough more women get
assaulted and murdered he's put back in
jail yet again but this time he finally
makes it to trial somehow he manages to
find time to get a woman pregnant and
marry her in court will you marry me
your honor yeah and then gets found
guilty and sentenced to the electric
chair throughout this whole story Ted's
partner Liz clings to the hope that he
was innocent despite being the one who
initially phoned him into the police
Ted Ted Bundy the movie ends with Liz
demanding to know the truth from sweet
teddy boy who writes hacksaw on the
prison glass and that counts as an
admission I guess prompting a flashback
to one of his many murders we then see
some of the real-life news footage of
scenes depicted in the movie over the
credits the end even just from that
brief summary you kind of get the feel
for how much the movie leaves out and
how much it enjoys having Efron as the
lead throughout the film were forced to
pay attention to how Bundy looks and how
handsome he is and not necessarily what
the character has or hasn't done purely
from the fact that teen choice male
hottie Award winner Zac Efron portrays
Bundy you know were being encouraged to
buy into Bundy's attractiveness even
beyond the casting the movie pushes the
idea of hot Bundy with the way the movie
sees the character some of the first
shots of the film are women gazing coyly
and seductively at the camera from
Bundy's point of view when he escapes
for the first time he stops regularly
along the street to wink and smile at
women who all reciprocate several women
are seen being interviewed who say how
cute he is and immediately conflate that
with how he must be innocent I'm not
afraid of him he just doesn t want to
type to kill somebody and well wouldn't
you I mean come on look at that smile
even the way Efron is filmed makes you
desire the character of Bundy we see
Efron both semi nude and butt-naked as
well as multiple sex scenes either
repeatedly flashback to or lingered on
in the moment what we're saying is this
movie wants to bang Zac Efron and it
wants you to as well which I believe is
known as laying a thirst trap if we're
being generous this could be what's
smart about the film even Bundy's judge
said how sad it was that such a bright
young man was going to the electric
chair it's a tragedy to this poor to see
such a total waste act the humanity that
I've experienced right the reason we
even know that fact is because he was
one of the first televised court cases
mostly because Bundy was so unassuming
and handsome the movie could be trying
to depict him as a central figure in the
move toward docudrama style new
reporting that we're so familiar with
today whether it's the OJ Simpson trial
or the serial podcast Bundy's
attractiveness can be seen as patient
zero for this move towards
sensationalism and media if we're to
understand this reaction to Bundy we
need to see him as handsome and who
better to accomplish that than High
School Musical heartthrob Zac Efron well
maybe but to understand why his casting
and the way he shot makes us
uncomfortable
we need to dip into some philosophy
specifically the philosophy of
aesthetics aesthetics is a pretty broad
term but it can be briefly summarized as
the philosophy of art the word gets its
modern usage from Alexander Baumgarten
whose text Aesthetica a word which had
until then meant sensation redefined it
to mean a study of good and bad taste
regarding art and beauty typical of
enlightenment thinking bound garden was
trying to apply principles of logic and
reason to subjective choices today the
study of aesthetics has branched out to
almost everything beyond art to the
point where my haircut and t-shirts are
aesthetic choices it's all about
subjective things like beauty taste and
appearances in film aesthetics can not
only be about its appearance in the
traditional sense but the variety of
choices that we might call artistic
think framing points of view editing
costumes the music or how all this
congeals into a mood aesthetics is a big
part of the Bundy story because they
both deal with the subjective appraisal
of certain things especially things we
think of as being beautiful beyond
casting a sex icon as Bundy the film
makes a series of aesthetic choices to
play up his appeal it's well shot with
naturalistic lighting uses traditionally
attractive framing and makes use of
sympathetic film grain that is to say
it's not grungy like saw but visually
appealing the production and costume
design is certainly period-correct but
the characters especially Bundy are
wearing expensive and fashionable
clothes not just for the time but for
today too love that sweater Zac combine
that with the retro film stock moments
like the eight millimeter home movie
footage and the whole thing has the
appearance of an extended Instagram post
but deeper than that the almost total
lack of violence in the movie feels like
an aesthetic choice to some of Bundy's
murders are described in courts Trang
old with a pantyhose garage so tight
that her neck was constricted to half
its size but we don't see much more than
the occasional photograph of bloodstains
other than the last five minutes Bundy
is not shown harming anyone and when he
is the effectiveness of the scene is
driven by the sound design of that
hacksaw not the visuals
extremely wicked is aesthetically driven
just like the movie would argue the
trial and legacy of Bundy is itself
except there's that Goethe quote at the
start few people have the imagination
for reality this quote implies the
horrors the real-life Bundy enacted
should not or cannot be imagined yet by
removing them almost entirely is the
movie asking us to imagine them this is
what people were forced to do with the
real Bundy at the time so the filmmakers
make the aesthetic choice to keep his
violence largely hidden if it's not
asking us to imagine the crimes then
should we just forget them if the movie
with holds a sense of disgust and we
come away from it thinking Ted Bundy was
more sexy than horrific is that okay
what responsibility do filmmakers have
to convince us that bad people are bad
this discussion on the aesthetic of evil
and the intersection of aesthetics and
ethics is something society has
struggled with throughout history from
the devil and Milton's Paradise Lost to
Nazis wearing Hugo Boss the idea of bad
things being beautiful has always
troubled us so how do we best represent
that in art for example consider the
movie American Psycho our protagonist or
the guy we're supposed to relate to is a
serial killer we actually kind of like
Patrick Bateman and want him to get what
he wants but the film under the watchful
eye of director mary harron and with a
masterful performance by Christian Bale
is able to achieve a tone in which we're
convinced that were not supposed to take
Patrick Bateman entirely seriously this
is the aesthetic of the film so just
because the hero of the movie is a
serial killer the movie doesn't
celebrate serial killing if it did it
would probably be a bad movie that we
would all hate this would be us making
an ethical judgment in response to the
aesthetic choice this interplay between
aesthetics and ethics has been explored
endlessly by philosophers like
Baumgarten Immanuel Kant sheila's and
jacques ranciere a few but to figure out
how to evaluate Efron's bundy we're
turning to theorist mary Deveraux in her
essay beauty and evil she analyzes Leni
Riefenstahl infamous Nazi propaganda
film triumph of the will and explains
that it used a lot of innovative
techniques for what was meant to be a
documentary
riefenstahl used dynamic camera
movements only seen in fiction movies of
that era by training camera operators to
shoot while wearing roller skates she
dressed her crew in uniforms to hide
them amongst the crowds and shot over 60
hours of footage that was edited
together in dynamic ways as Devereux
puts it leaf installs concerns were
aesthetic which meant the end result for
the film is a beautiful vision of Hitler
and new Germany that is morally
repugnant if the film is beautifully
made but with a terrible message it
should be possible to separate these two
factors Devereaux defines this
distinction between the aesthetic
appraisal of a work of art from a moral
one as aesthetic formalism acknowledging
that these two considerations may pull
in different directions and should
therefore be judged distinctly or as she
memorably puts it you can admire the
beauty of a fog at sea
despite its danger except Deveraux
argues that isn't in fact possible
because admiring that fog will get you
killed a lot of triumphs of the Wills
aesthetic principles are tied to its
content until her death riefenstahl
insisted the film was not propaganda it
was a documentary but we can't ignore
that her creative choices were
overwhelmingly driven by a desire to
make Hitler and the Nazis look appealing
whether that's with interviews of people
who solely express positive views about
Hitler admiring shots of the
goose-stepping soldiers or just the fact
that it was shot specifically at a huge
grandiose Pro Nazi rally with hundreds
of thousands of attendees this is a
movie about how popular the Nazis were
Devereaux explains that ever since Plato
made the connection society has always
equated beauty with goodness an idea
that has long been associated with the
study of aesthetics but it's only in the
relatively recent past that we've moved
away from this idea largely because of
fascist groups like the Nazis who
demanded racial purity and the
resurrection of classical architecture
the aesthetic of the modernist movement
after World War Two resulted in very not
beautiful things like brutalist
architecture and bold abstract graphic
design to try to reconcile the ugliness
of a post-war world against the Nazis
desire for pure
and beauty beauty is no longer central
to art as Devereaux puts it but art can
certainly render evil beautiful because
of that she says the best way to engage
with something like triumph of the will
is not to separate its aesthetic
principles from its moral ones but to
quote engage with its vision the vision
she refers to is what purpose the work
of art has and how it is presented in
film this means the story themes and
aesthetic should be critically read as a
whole by this standard Riefenstahl film
is not a good world of art not in spite
of its aesthetic choices but because of
them it is a film specifically designed
to make the Nazis and the awfulness that
went with them appealing / dubrow there
is a reason to withhold the highest
aesthetic praise from works that present
as beautiful attractive and good what is
in fact evil so if we want to understand
how something evil can be represented as
beautiful and vice versa
it's worth considering what the vision
for extremely wicked is we're gonna do
that by comparing it to another Ted
Bundy biopic there's a ton of them by
the way we just picked one out of the
Hat
the aptly titled Ted Bundy from 2002
this movie is a much lower budget much
more graphic retelling of the Bundy
story and his crimes it covers the same
sort of time frame as the Efron movie
but goes all in on depicting many of
Bundy's rapes and murders and unlike
extremely wicked it's entirely
disinterested with his appearance a
scene at the beginning where Bundy looks
into the mirror and rehearses his
greeting either
hi there my name is Ted nice to meet you
makes the point to the audience that his
charm and attracted this is false and he
has to practice it he's seen as
charismatic by some characters but we
also see him rubbing one out in a bush
which kind of takes the sheen off him
beyond simply not wanting to make the
character attractive to the audience
this film's entire aesthetic is
completely different than the Efron
movie its budget means the picture
quality and cinematography is nowhere
near as crisp as extremely wicked the
period details and costumes are paid
lip-service - but aren't as in-depth the
violence is visceral and lingered on and
unlike Efron's depiction at the end we
see bundy humiliated in prison and died
on screen in a graphic way this
low-budget video nasty aesthetic seems
more interested in showing us the horror
of what Ted Bundy did and who he really
was
as such the visions for the two films
despite telling the same story couldn't
be more different extremely wicked wants
to tell Ted Bundy story but maintain an
appealing aesthetic in much the same way
as the real Bundy did the problem with
this vision for the movie ie the way
it's aesthetic works with its story and
themes is that it's more interested in
how it presents itself then telling you
the real story of Ted Bundy by focusing
on the perspective of Liz Kendall's
character and what she knows about Bundy
we spend most of the time just as
confused as her as to how we should feel
about him it's also really uneven in
that it doesn't actually spend that much
time with Kendall throughout the movie
we see the personal effect of the trial
on her and her romance with the kid from
The Sixth Sense but we spend far more
time with Bundy if they were trying to
tell the movie from the perspective of
someone other than Bundy it makes sense
that we wouldn't have seen his crimes
except that isn't the story being told
the majority is told from Bundy's
perspective and Kendall's so why don't
we see his murders the movie tries to
juggle these two perspectives but
doesn't fully commit to either and as a
result tells the story of a sexy man
less than a sexy serial killer if the
movie only wanted to give us a vision of
Ted Bundy as a pop figure it did a great
job but if people come away from the
movie seeing him as more of a sex symbol
than a mass murderer is that okay the
2002 Ted Bundy movies intent on the
other hand
is to show a repugnant man for what he
was and it certainly does accomplish
that but importantly that doesn't
necessarily make it a good movie the
movie is bad for other reasons in the
end both movies fail but it's extremely
wicked that suffers in the most Awkward
creepy way given the publicity
surrounding its release and the headline
friendly casting of Zac Efron
expectations were high and while we can
see what it was going for its
preoccupation with its own aesthetic
thieves the view were wondering what was
the point of that what people think of
as beauty comes with its own set of
standards like clean straight lines
symmetry and a lack of blemishes but all
these things require hiding or removing
something deemed unattractive the
real-life Ted Bundy knew this and used
it to horrific effect by presenting
himself as appealing and hiding the
worst parts of himself
Netflix's movie does exactly the same
thing but what do you think wisecrack is
Efron's bundy worthy of another Teen
Choice Award or should one of the most
prolific serial killers in American
history be depicted as ugly as he really
was thanks to all our patrons who
support the channel and our podcast be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
before you go don't forget to check out
ray con wireless earbuds for half the
price of most competitors you definitely
want to snag these high-quality stylish
earbuds check out the link in the
description to get 20% off your order
today and as always thanks for watching
guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]